in our shocking research on phalloplasty
it says that 40% of the time they end up
in continent because they can't because
they lose control of the muscle that we
all release when it's time to pee yeah
they also uh bleed they have a lot of
cramps um they have to constantly go to
the toilet and they're basically in pain
for the rest of their life and then if a
man becomes uh with woman parts you know
a vagina plasty they have to use a
dilator every single week for the rest
of their life and there was a case if
you know Jazz Jennings who has the
reality TV show you know and her mom who
has transitioned her since she was a kid
and also encourages other parents to
transition their kids she was bragging
about it you know joking about and you
can see this this young kid you know
she's about 18 19 now JZ Jennings she is
really really suffering with her mental
health you see it on the screen and it's
heartbreaking and the mom is bragging
that oh don't worry you can use a
dilator and that's the reality of what
these uh people that transition have to
go through they're never going to be
able to have these parts functioning
normally